Nancy Rios: Go ahead and get started.
Nancy Rios: So,
Nancy Rios: Yeah, thank you guys for being here. We'll go ahead and get started. You… you guys made it to the first cohort. this is a learning experience for both of us, for, ourselves, and for…
Nancy Rios: you as being the student. My name is Nancy, I am the program coordinator with CTI, and I'll be facilitating as well as, Sophia, this first session. We'll go ahead and,
Nancy Rios: get started on a few things that we wanted to touch on before we actually jump into the content. But,
Nancy Rios: The team would like to quickly introduce themselves as well.
Sathya Narayanan: Nicholas, do you want to start us off?
Nicolas Guerrero: Yeah, I can go first. Hi, my name's Nicholas Guerrero, CTI alum, and I guess now working for CTI. I do some course development, I'm gonna be helping Nancy with career intelligence.
Sathya Narayanan: Satina Rainan, I'm a computer science professor at CSUMB. I'm the director of CTI. Been in this space for, like, about 20 years or so. In the last 5 years, I've been running CTI to serve, kind of, more students beyond students at CSUMB.
Sathya Narayanan: Jeff? Is Jeff here? Jeff is there, yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: Hey, everyone. Great to be here with you. My name's Jeff DeAndrea. I'm here to provide the industry perspective. I'm former tech recruiter with Microsoft and TikTok on their college recruiting teams for intern, new grad roles.
Jeff D'Andria: specifically software engineer, but also hired for some other stuff. And then I've worked on the education side,
Jeff D'Andria: I've worked at Stanford's Career Center with their CS students, I've worked at two boot camps, and then also now at the California Community Colleges, so it's a big spectrum there, and really, really excited to help y'all, land this role.
Nancy Rios: Awesome, thank you.